hey guys eric hair joined by rob and and
it turns out there's yet another exploit
in the division mm-hmm we seem to be
talking about this at least once a week
but um this not twice yeah yeah but this
time around it seems like there's a way
for you to boost your damage like
absurdly high as long as you have like a
specific talent and whatnot won't you
tell me more about the exploit yeah you
know boost your damage to the infinite
degree depending on how much you really
want i went to two million geez on my
weapons and it has to be a specific
weapons you see here on the right it's
the competent talent if you have that
perk on a weapon that's where you're
going to want fairly common perk but
anyways you equip this thing in your
number one slot the perk itself is you
know weapon damage is increased by
thirteen percent if you use a skill so
this is like basically playing on using
a skill and then getting this insane dps
then get a sticky bomb you don't have to
fire it you cancel it aim it cancel it
somehow this skill is then engaged on
the weapon then you go back into your
inventory this is where it gets just
freaking insane and you just do this you
switch between the weapon that has the /
and an X whatever I met weapon and you
go like that forever the estimate i
would say is like five to ten minutes
you can get like 1.5 million on yours
easy yes and so I did this for a while
and yeah Jane like okay so tell me how
you you know we either re-engage the
damage or like what are things that
might cause you to lose the damage is
it's something that you just get for
like the 10 seconds that the perk says
or is it kind of just like you keep it
forever yeah well as far as engaging it
again you know it's it's I'd say it's
like a few kills you can get off of it
so here's like here's me I don't have it
on a turn on just like that and then BAM
name that me down but yeah there are
some things that i noticed that will
lose it so if you choose to go the darks
it works in the dark zone as well so if
you choose to go dark zone what you
should not do is if you die do not spawn
at a check
points spawn at a safe house and you
will still retain that exploit work
again okay safe house instead of a
checkpoint otherwise it gets reset yeah
last other thing is switching gear items
will turn it off gotcha but I think you
did also tell me that like when you did
do that you lost it but then you were
able to I think in that moment switch
back to the armor you had like made the
exploit or snapshot dps on yeah and then
it was ok but yeah ideally you want to
be ready ahead of time nicely but you
know again like who knows how long this
is gonna last of course I'm sure you
know massive and Ubisoft they probably
already know but you know thanks Rob for
telling me about the exploit yep thanks
Eric